so I talked about Santos and Deadpool
not yet not yet but again I'm a I don't
know no I don't I don't but I don't
break it's not that I don't break the
fourth wall there's there's a lot of
stuff going on a Deadpool that's very
surprising and that will be very
satisfying when you see it it to me it's
even funnier than the first one that's
to me when they asked me to do it I was
like I I do that Deadpool and I'm doing
the Thanos thing right now and should I
do and my wife just said read it like
why are you even thinking just read it
and I read it and I laugh harder than I
was last in a very long time so it's on
it so cables a funny cable the funny
villain cable can be very funny he can
be a lot of different things but he also
can be very funny are you [ __ ]
kidding no not on my watch [ __ ]
hey youtubers happy new comic book day
so I figured it was about time to do a
Deadpool video because they've been
posting so many behind-the-scenes
pics of cable josh brolin buy all the
tickets to the gun show so there's a lot
of funny stuff happening behind the
scenes like Ryan Reynolds is taking
every opportunity he can to poke fun at
spider-man Tom Holland even retweeted
this it's like oh yeah yeah we're
filming spider-man downtown thank you so
much vancouver police but we've also
gotten our first look at za z beats as
dominos she looks fantastic
she is freakin hot so what i'll do
there's a couple easter eggs in these
cable photos they've been posting not as
many Domino easter egg she's pretty
straight up like her powers are
relatively easy to explain cable is a
little trickier because of his origin
story and how complicated it gets so
i'll explain a little bit about what's
going on but some of you may have
already spotted the really big easter
egg so if you are finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything the entire season of
Defenders is dropping next week so
there's going to be a whole bunch of
videos for that too but cable this is
obviously the stripped down version josh
brolin i think looks great and this is
just a mock-up so the CG will look a
little bit more fantastic like they
always polish it but they wanted to show
people pretty much what he's going to
look like this is like 90% it is
probably what he's going to look like
through most of the movie you can see
looking at this real world picture where
they add the CG so like he has the
motion capture dots like drawn onto his
neck here for a lot of this and then
obviously his arm is all CG too but they
probably have a couple prosthetics that
they wear for certain scenes but
probably the reason they opted for a
stripped down version of cable is this
because when you look at Rob Liefeld
original designs like this is the first
time he's appearing on screen so while I
do think the movies story is original in
the way that they change Deadpool's
origin story for the first Deadpool
movie there'll be a lot of references
for New Mutants 98 when he and Deadpool
fought each other for the first time
which was also the first appearance of
Domino so they'll have a lot of fun with
that look at this design of Rob Liefeld
cable like this is not a human figure
here like he just does not resemble
something that exists in nature so while
he's a really cool character it's just
as they have to make him look real on
screen
order to achieve this Josh Brolin's head
would either have to shrink down a
couple sizes worried have to be on
steroids the next three years it's a lot
easier for za z beets to resemble that
comic book model cable is just like over
the top he's probably one of the biggest
x-men characters next to Colossus and
beast but I am expecting liberal pouches
jokes that's another big Liefeld
criticism is that he puts a crazy
pouches all over his early character
designs he was really young when he did
that step two so I don't have to feel
like I'm criticizing it too much it's
just that you know you look at this and
you remember all the original cable
jokes and you're like okay yeah clearly
what they're going for here is a version
of the classic Liefeld pouch scheme but
it sort of stripped down to fit Josh
Brolin's body like it's proportionate to
the rest of the stuff that he's carrying
around in cables use all kinds of guns
I'm not a big gun aficionado
so let me know if you know exactly what
kind of modified gun he's using here
because it actually looks like something
from present day but the whole thing is
that he's a time traveler and they said
that even though they're changing his
backstory I think there'll be an element
of that to it they just won't fully
explain it till future movies but the
big Easter eggs that you probably
spotted that's been driving everybody
crazy is the worn down teddy bear that's
attached to his belt like he carries it
around everywhere he goes with them so
people like what does that mean is that
a reference to hope from the comics are
they actually going to include her what
I actually think is going on is that you
know because cable is a very terminator
inspired character like a really
hardcore version of John Connor who
instead of sending Kyle Reese back in
time comes back himself and tries to
change the future so you have to imagine
this post-apocalyptic or apocalypse
future that he's from where everything
has just gone to complete [ __ ] he grew
up with this teddy bear it's a keepsake
given to him by his parents Cyclops and
Madeline prior who's a Jean Grey
look-alike but just because they've been
talking about how they had to
oversimplify his backstory is just way
too complicated to do it exactly like it
is in the comics that I think that in
the name of simplicity they're not going
to do hope it'll just be cable and it's
his teddy bear that was given to him as
a child by the x-men that we'll be
seeing next year during Dark Phoenix
so it should go without saying that I
don't think we're ever going to see
those Dark Phoenix characters which that
movie's taking place in the 90s I don't
think we'll ever see them crossover with
this version of Deadpool and cable in
this way like they want you to see the
teddy bear and if you've read the comics
you sort of know the connection and
you're like oh that teddy bears probably
seen some [ __ ] but the whole idea of
when you meet him for the first time is
that he's just this hardcore character
that you can't quite figure out like
what's this teddy bear like what has he
been through why is he so crazy what
disaster is he trying to stop and was is
it the throws him into Deadpool's past
like that's all you're worried about
then after that like they slowly start
peeling back the layers and he starts
telling stories about the stuff that's
happened to him maybe a few offhanded
references about his parents but I not
expecting any direct shoutouts or any
appearances from Cyclops or his parents
or anything like that
the original dynamic is the Domino is
sort of a mercenary for hire on her own
but she helps cable out so they're both
kind of on the same team when Deadpool
pops up for the first time trying to
kill cable so I'm expecting a similar
dynamic but if you've read that original
New Mutants story it's a little more
straight-up like I'm coming to kill you
with a little bit of wisecracking I
think the way that Ryan Reynolds plays
the character is a little bit more
casual like even when he's getting into
it during the first Deadpool movie the
way he talks when he's fighting the
villains is still relatively nonchalant
like this is no big deal I'm just going
to most of these guys on the way to
saving my girlfriend but I'm finished I
like to grow back here good one yeah
good one let's dance
so if you've been seeing the pictures
from behind the scenes like him crashing
a party in someone's backyard and what
looks like the suburbs him riding on a
scooter through Midtown then it just
seems like it's going to be a lot of the
same tone like part of the comedy of
Deadpool is the fact that there's all
this crazy [ __ ] going on in normal
superheroes even people on the Avengers
would be freaking out like you see
Captain America getting all depressed
about how crazy things of God you'd see
spider-man freaking out but Deadpool
just takes it all in like it's no big
deal just another day of the races
just going to work gonna kill a whole
lot of people like he's a blue-collar
stiff just punching his timecard I know
a lot of you are wondering what his
powers are
look like on screen because it isn't the
stripped down version of cable does that
mean they're also going to strip down
his comic book power levels because he's
telekinetic he has very fine control of
objects like he's actually really good
with it
he's telepathic but not quite as
powerful as Professor X or Jean Grey and
he's very good at astral projection so
what I'm expecting is is that we're not
going to see any astral projection we
might see a limited form of telepathy in
maybe a little bit of telekinesis but I
don't think it's going to be off the
charts look at the power levels during
x-men apocalypse like everybody's off
the charts especially the four horsemen
it's not going to be anywhere like that
in fact they're probably going to make
fun of that people just being super opie
[Music]
Deadpool is all about making fun of
those kind of things so either he has no
powers or he just has very limited
powers but everybody let me know what
you think about Josh Brolin and za ZB so
far I think they look pretty solid but
in related news there's a whole bunch of
comic book stuff that's been happening
this week so like I said defenders is
dropping next week I'll be doing episode
videos for that there's a new Rick and
Morty Marvel episode they're genuinely
doing a Marvel parody in next week's
episode little air on Sunday so we'll do
a promo video for that that'll post in a
couple hours later tonight if you don't
know what Rick and Morty is you should
definitely start watching or at least
check the videos out that I do for it
and then start watching it but while you
wait for everything you can click here
for next week's game of Thrones footage
and you can click here for my infinity
war trailer videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight